Czechoslovakia came into existence after
the collapse of the austr Hungarian
Empire it was a state made up of both
Czechs and slovaks and also rians but as
many of you will know the Czechs and the
slovaks were both separate during their
time under the hapsburgs with the Czech
lands being run as the kingdom of
bohemia and Moravia and the Slovak clans
were a part of Hungary but why was it
that when the austr Hungarian empire
fell apart these two peoples combined to
form Czechoslovakia instead of both
being independent separately so when
Austria Hungary became embroiled in the
first first world war both people saw an
opportunity the man that led the
movement to break away from Vienna and
Budapest was toas mazerik who pushed for
both Czechs and slovaks to build a
single country after Independence he
personally wanted to create
Czechoslovakia because he was born here
and so grew up surrounded by both
peoples and saw their cultural
similarities but beyond this there were
pragmatic reasons for the union the
first reason was safety the founders of
Czechoslovakia believed that they needed
each other if they were to survive the
designs of their neighbors there were
some mild disagreements with Poland to
the north over some territ teritory but
prague's main concern was Germany or
more specifically the number of Germans
living on its western border there had
been a push after the war that people
should have the right to
self-determination for example Danes
living in Germany were given the choice
of whether to stay a part of Germany or
join Denmark and this trend worried the
Czech since it would give Germany a
claim to important territory or the
Germans living there voting to take it
with them the slovaks had similar
concerns in the South sat a large number
of hungarians and Hungary had made it
clear that they wanted these lands and
its people back furthermore a on the
death of Austria Hungary this area
called Carpathian ruthenia was also
given to Czechoslovakia the people there
were neither Slovak nor Czech but
instead were ruthenians they had
initially wanted to become a part of the
Russian Empire but given that that
didn't exist anymore and what replaced
it was a tattoo communist for the
ruthenians liking and so it was decided
that it would go to Prague to avoid
creating a small state that would likely
just get conquered by Hungary again soon
afterwards the Allies wanted this for
two reasons it punished Hungary which
was always nice and also it connected
Czechoslovakia to Romania which was also
worried about Hungary trying to retake
old lands and so when these three ethnic
groups were combined the country had a
much greater chance of resisting any
foreign threats the second reason was
that whilst the Czech lands had a great
deal of Industry its agricultural lands
weren't that great whereas in Slovakia
it was the opposite and as such the two
could help each other with Slovakia
racting as a bread basket for the
country whilst the Czechs would provide
the means of modernizing Slovakia by
building new factories in a university
there the rights of non checks in the
country were guaranteed by the League of
Nations in 1919 this of course had one
exception the Polish since they were
added to the country in 1920 when
Czechoslovakia occupied these lands
there were concerns about the German
regions in the west of the country but
the PRI government lied about how many
Germans there were and also it was
inconceivable that either Germany or
Austria would receive lands after the
war and with that the Czechs and slovaks
left not on their own but United in a
single country I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James Bizet Kelly moneymaker Sky
Chappelle kitka Andy McGee Anthony
Becket Alex Schwin rodie Martin Udan
Wang AF Firefly Spencer Lightfoot Marcus
arner Y and hockey Captain side dog
Marvin CAU Kon Yun the MC Whopper Gustav
Swan Maggie Paskowski calling Dr Howard
Dr Fine Dr Howard spinning three plates
copper tone shenin words about books
podcast Ked Alder Wood Winston kwood Jim
Stromberg Charles I and miss
iset